why do you think some talented and
lovable child actors having have trouble
making that leap crossing over and
sometimes turning on themselves
I think child actors have difficulty
transitioning to being an adult for a
number of reasons one depending upon how
famous they were when they were kids and
how they were treated and how indulge
they were is very dangerous it's
dangerous too if you're just a parent to
treat your children with kid gloves let
alone imagine all of them the luxuries a
celebrity child gets and then becomes
accustomed to it and then you know you
saw me and Christmas story not a
handsome kid and I'm getting this big
like I hit this stage when I was a
little kid I had little nose I had big
eyes I had like these cheeks chubby
cheeks
I hit a certain age like I got the thing
came out I had the braces you know
everybody's got this period in their
life where their hormones are just
trying to make them as a sexually an
unattractive as possible so to go
through that and to continue working is
is really difficult and then I guess it
also depends there's construction
outside so it might speak up it also
depends what it is you want to
accomplish because if your goals when
you were a kid was to be doubted no not
doubted fawned over is where I'm looking
for it to be fond over and pet in the
head and praise well then as soon as
you're off set and on the red carpet
then no one cares and if your show ends
and the pewag know yeah whatever
happened to you if your job is to if
what you find satisfaction in is the
process of it then you're gonna keep on
pushing forward and when I was a kid I
shoveled walks I grew up very very poor
so when I was like 6 years old I was
shoveling snow off of neighbors walks
for anywhere from 30 to 50 cents per pop
I was delivering newspapers I was
working as a stock boy
worked in kitchens worked at a guy named
Taub was a shimada's dealer I worked for
my dad
painting and cleaning and brooming and
then I got into martial arts when I was
ten ten to eleven a couple of to three
years there I was doing fencing they got
in a Taekwondo and I get into boxing and
then I had a bunch of amateur fights and
then I traveled but the thing is I like
being in the gym I like being in the
dojo I like doing the bag work I like
doing the ground work I like getting
stronger I like doing the job I like
eating but I like cooking the meal I
like being in the kitchen using the
knives cutting the stuff up and making
it look cool and putting new flavors
together I like the process I don't just
want people go yeah you here's food I
want to actually make it so I took that
attitude towards working and it wasn't
about the red carpet for me because in
Canada I never got a red carpet
I think that was a saving grace and I I
think again I'll reiterate it make your
own stuff I have a friend of mine James
comer ESIC this little bastard is 22
years old and as directed 12 movies dick
if you're watching it James you're a
dick and he his first one I mean he's 18
years old getting it out there and he
used social media to launch it as high
as he could and he's calling all the
film festival like I'm a 19 year old
filmmaker take pity on me and he made a
pretty crappy movie but guess what they
all wrote him up and he got an Amazon I
was on like in the top 30 of all movies
all and his movie not so bueno but the
fact is he got it he's doing it he's
doing it he's doing it he's doing it and
because
did it cuz he didn't stop he didn't wait
for someone else to give it to him and I
think with younger actors when they're
trying to transition if the sorry I mean
it that when they become back in my day
especially I think what you're
referencing is the different strokes
kids and the Corey Feldman's and the
Corey Haims and the people who ended up
being kind of disasters and doing
cocaine and getting heavily into the
drugs and and making bad decisions and I
know exactly why they did that and I
didn't have that success when I was a
kid I I would say the closest I got to
that was really when I was doing Titus
and I had a 500-person audience and in
the last season the Titus I was like a
Beatle like I had kids lined up
boys and girls cuz the character was
kind of androgynous ly sexual towards
both genders which is awesome and you're
like we love you and I'm like I'm
married but thank you very much
and I do remember like the high of that
live performance being so great and
wanting that not to stop I started to
drink too much because at that point I
wasn't writing I wasn't pursuing
financing I wasn't going on lynda.com
learning how to edit I wasn't going to
the National associate broadcaster show
in Vegas and talking to everybody and
asking about how software works and
asking questions I wasn't buying tools I
was buying toys and hoping things were
gonna work out for me no one taught me I
had to figure it the out and I
wanted that high to continue and so I
click click click 'ln ike leggett
equipment and that wasn't I'm not a you
don't get smarter getting drunker you
don't get anything else accomplished she
talked about it - we should showed you
that thing or a jargon of it and you're
awesome for that and then you wake up
you're like what happened oh that's
gross did we shoot that movie no we just
talked about it crap so I understand why
they did that in the eighties those kids
and because they couldn't grab a camera
or they felt they couldn't grab
amaura but now cameras and editing gear
and a portal for distribution being
YouTube or whatever you want to try it's
ubiquitous it's everywhere it's
affordable you can borrow it you know if
your buddy has a camera and you don't
paint his house borrow his hard
work will get you everything you need
pretty much and then talent and more
hard work gets it than the next way and
I so I hope nowadays that people can
feel the freedom to transition and still
feel creative like I'm a don't blink
I'm an actor for 35 years now I'd like
to be acting the rest of my life but
more importantly I'd like to be creating
for the rest of my life and if I'm not
in front of the camera because my name
infront of the camera is not bringing
money to the to the production then okay
let somebody else have that position
because that's respect for my investors
but I also get to be creative my life
doesn't end because I'm not on the red
carpet where I'm not the one being
interviewed
I'd just be as happy asking the
questions
you